europe is also having its worst coveted
outbreak since april with an average of
more than 70 000 new cases a day
over the past two weeks italy just
reported a record one-day number
meanwhile britain's prime minister is
fighting with local officials over new
restrictions there
and france is cracking down even more as
our liz palmer reports
last night people in france tuned in to
hear a covet update from
president emmanuel macron
the situation is worrying he said but we
shouldn't panic
but he did declare a state of emergency
and a curfew in nine
cities including paris everyone will
have to leave
cafes and restaurants and be off the
streets by nine in the evening
and stay put until six a.m
a second wave of coronavirus has taken
hold
the rate of infection for example in
france the netherlands
spain and the uk is climbing steeply
overall in europe there's now an average
of seventy thousand new cases
a day let's try to avoid the misery
of another national lockdown in britain
prime minister johnson has imposed a
series of
halfway measures like closing pubs early
and limiting
social gatherings to six people
but it's not working his scientific
advisors are pushing for a temporary but
strict lockdown a so-called circuit
breaker
to get things back under control i think
it's going to have to
and the longer it leaves it the the
worse it will be and the longer we'll
have to keep it in place
there is huge frustration with the
government
here over its constant changing of the
rules and a dysfunctional track and
trace system
surveys say that people would accept
another lockdown
what they really want is some clarity
tony
don't we all elizabeth palmer for us in
london thank you very much